hey everyone welcome back I'm James
Murphy and this is M coding today we're
going to be talking about a code smell
that I recently encountered
the smell I'm talking about is Lambda
inside a loop
so first off what's a code smell well a
code smell is kind of like other smells
in real life if you smell something
really smelly that doesn't necessarily
mean that it's bad but you might want to
look into it
there can be really smelly things that
turn out to be just fine I'm looking at
you cheese but most of the time if
something smells really strongly there's
a problem
basically what I'm saying is that if you
see a Lambda inside a loop then you
might want to take another look because
this is usually not what you want
but before we move on give me just 30
seconds to talk about my favorite
sponsor of all time myself that's right
I'm sponsoring my own video this video
is sponsored by m coding which is my
consulting company we do Consulting
Contracting training and interview prep
whether you're a programmer an engineer
whatever you are if you have a software
project at your company that you think
deserves some outside eyes please do
Reach Out emcoding dot IO
thanks for listening let's get back to
the video so without further delay let's
dive into this example this example is
from a real code base of course the code
has been drastically simplified to fit
on one-ish screen for you and it's been
changed significantly to protect the
guilty parties
it's me I'm the guilty party so here's
the basic setup we have some work that
needs to be done meaning functions that
need to be called some of them might
take a long time to complete but the
catches were in a GUI application so the
real example this comes from a GUI
application we can't just call these
functions on the main thread because
that's where the GUI runs if one of
these functions takes a long time to
complete then our application is frozen
until it completes so instead we'll run
things in a thread pool using a thread
pool executor we Loop through all of our
work and submit each function that needs
to be called as a task to the executor
the functions will eventually get called
on a separate thread and we'll use done
callbacks in order to keep track of
which ones have completed
in this demo code I'm actually creating
the threadpool executor right here and
then when the with block ends it will
actually wait for all the tasks to
complete in the real GUI application the
executor was a pre-existing object and
we also don't wait for all the tasks to
finish at the end of the function
instead we just do this interloop
basically submitting more functions into
the executor and adding the Callback in
particular the real version of this
function is not a blocking call
but it still has the same problem with
Lambda in a loop
so here's how we actually call the
function
down in Maine we're creating our list of
work
each piece of work is just made up of
some unique ID and then the callable
that I'm supposed to call in this demo
our work is just printing out ABCD but
of course in a real use case these could
be complex calculations or doing
whatever you want
as with some of the worst kinds of
Errors when we run the code everything
appears to be working just fine
well bacd those definitely ran out of
order but that's not really a problem we
were submitting these things to run on
multiple different threads the fact that
they completed out of order should be
expected
and from our callback we see that
completed was printed four times so they
all seem to be called just fine
the problem actually shows itself when
we run this again trying to print out
the actual task ID instead of just the
word completed
apparently task C completed twice but
task B never completed
I guess you just double shipped one
customer's order and lost another
customer's order
well no because our tasks actually
printed out ABCD we can see that each of
ABCD ran exactly once so here it's
pretty clear that the problem is in this
printing of the task completed and not
with the execution of the tasks
themselves
but in the more realistic scenario where
the tasks are not printing out their own
names and these task completed messages
in the logs are all you have to go off
of then this might make for a very
alarming log
so back to the dispatch code what
exactly is the problem with this
function and in particular with the
Lambda
the problem is that I used a Lambda in a
loop and because of the way that lambdas
work the task ID that the Lambda uses is
not the value of task ID when the Lambda
was created
instead the value that the Lambda uses
for task ID is whatever the value
happens to be in the current local
variables of this function
meaning when the future finishes and the
Callback runs it's going to use the
value of the last submitted task ID not
the task ID for this task
we can see the most extreme version of
this by sleeping a little bit longer to
ensure that all the tasks are submitted
before the first one finishes in that
case they'll all be using the same value
of task ID the last one
and that's what we see it looks like
task D was completed four times when in
actuality the actual work shows that
each task ran once
I do have another video explaining how
these weird variable lookups work but in
this video let's just focus on how do we
fix it
luckily it's a pretty easy fix
99.9 of the time when you have Lambda in
a loop what you really wanted was Funk
tools partial
the first argument is the function that
you want to call and then you can pass
in any subsequent arguments or keyword
arguments that you want to pre-fill for
that function
add done callback expects a function
that accepts just one argument a future
so for this function we just need to
pre-fill the task IDE and then leave the
future argument not filled
the important distinction here that
makes func tools partial work where the
Lambda did not is it functional's
partial actually stores this value the
task ID somewhere inside of itself
whereas the Lambda was trying to look up
the value in this outer scope
each functional is partial stores a
different task ID the current one
whereas the lambdas we're all trying to
look up the same task ID which is this
local variable
now when we run it we see what we'd hope
each task is logged as completed exactly
once
but of course there are always
exceptions although this use case of a
Lambda in a loop was bad it's not always
bad there's only certain situations
where this is a problem the thing that
made this a problem in this case is that
we're using this variable task ID which
is not a global variable and it's not an
argument of the function it's a variable
that needs to be looked up in this outer
scope
if you weren't using any such variable
then it's just not a problem
it also wouldn't be a problem if you
were just immediately invoking the
Lambda in which case you are using the
most current value of task ID but doing
something like this is pretty rare
that's more of a C plus plus thing if
you know what I mean
and I guess I should come clean yes this
is not just a Lambda problem if you
defined a local function it has all the
exact same problems
in my experience though when I see this
mistake in real code it always seems to
be a Lambda not a local function
it's almost like people sometimes just
use Lambda because it's less typing and
less thinking rather than because it's
the most appropriate choice for the
situation
you know I've even heard some very
experienced programmers say that they
think all usages of Lambda are a code
smell
I'm not so sure about that but maybe
I'll get there
and my last tip for you is that like
many common problems in Python a good
linter can stop this before it ever
happens
let's run pilint on this example
I mean pretty aggressive for warning on
every module function or method that
doesn't have a doc string okay but you
can turn that off right
but as you can see here is the no Lambda
in a loop
of course they're not biased against
lambdas in particular this cell variable
is the more General terminology that
encapsulates both lambdas and function
definitions
yeah cell variable is more accurate but
no Lambda Loop is way catchier right
that's something that you can tell a
co-worker in one line no Lambda and a
loop
once again I'm James Murphy from M
coding thank you for watching and as
always thank you to my patrons and
donors for supporting the channel I
really appreciate the support if you
like my content please do subscribe and
if you really enjoy it consider becoming
a patron on patreon thanks and I'll see
you in the next one